this is a place today with an
understandable sensitivity
there hasn't been any bombing in this
region of western ukraine but people
here are following every detail of
what's going on where the bombs are
falling and preparations are underway
there are fortified checkpoints outside
the city we've been asked not to show
them
inside the city government buildings are
being fortified we're not supposed to
give much detail on that either the fear
is something shown in the media could be
used to identify potential targets but
we visited offices today that aren't
doing what they usually do this office
would normally hand out permits right
now it's where people who aren't in the
army go if they want to be given a
weapon there was also a tourist office
that's now a media center and we visited
a place that in regular times would be a
sort of artist workshop where they've
been preparing molotov cocktails each
one has a label with russian leader
vladimir putin on it calling him a bad
word we also dropped by a company that
makes t-shirts they've restarted
production so the staff can work but the
money they're raising goes to support
the ukrainian military
not all of us can go with the guns
i'm not the military one i
i i cannot shoot but still i can make
something that can shoot in the hearts
of the people all over the world
that company also asked that its
location not be identified no one wants
to be a potential target even a t-shirt
shop
mike armstrong global news la vie
ukraine